[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today is in
Santa Fe n Mexico hi JT how are you D
Jade how's it going better than we
deserve what's
up so I'm about to be at a point where
I'm completely out of debt I've been
working on the last few years and I'm
about to hit zero way to
go my question is is it
a is it food to go back into debt yes
start a business yes you just called the
ramsy show JT I
know you walked into the bear cave and
as the bear if it was
hungry you already know the answer JT
advice what's the
business uh my trade work is a I'm a
401k consultant I do a risk of
[Music]
compliance and I don't know it's kind to
start my own firm and it's a lot to try
to just bank roll why and why what do
you got to bank roll that's what I'm
wondering well a cash flow you day
one well I mean everything from you know
software agreements all sorts of stuff
wait a minute for what you don't even
you got to have customers
first well I mean I not so much worried
about that part of getting everything
started yeah but you're going fast what
are you getting
started what do you mean what I mean you
don't have any
money well I mean not enough to get this
thing going well what do you think it
takes to get this going why why have you
decid what you're describing to me you
need a computer and some sweat okay and
a customer yeah or
six well that's the thing you
know for what I'm doing I'd be go I'd be
whale hunting in a canoe and I need some
stuff to be able to do such things okay
you are not ready to open a business and
leave your job when you have absolutely
no customers whale hunting in a canoe
means that you don't have a clue where
your customers are coming from you're
not ready to open a business and has
nothing to do with a loan you need some
customers on the hook well the first
thing I do I would take my current job
and ask that they uh 1099 me and I would
contract all the work that I'm doing
right now and then go look for my own
bigger client so I have an idea for cash
flow okay so now we're eating now why
are we whale hunting in a
canoe well we got to go after big fish
to eat big right well uh no I mean
rabbits are more plentiful let's kill
some of those neat I think you're
missing the beauty of the type of
business that you're starting which is
this is a business you can start with
little to no overhead and little to no
cash yeah you need enough to eat on but
I don't want you floating in a canoe
looking for a whale starving to death
cuz you didn't have any plan or any
background but if you got a plan for
cash flow day one on the 1099 side then
um and you think they'll do that what's
the probability of them doing
that I think so because I'd be taking on
a lot of my uh you know I'd get my own
insurance and stuff like
that you know this is so vague and you
have not proformed this out the business
you're in demands that you do a better
job of Performing than you have done so
far this is a vague g a group vague
generalities and I'm going to go borrow
money no you don't need to borrow money
you need to organically cash flow this
little service oriented business and
you're going to be just fine uh and you
need to put together a business plan and
process that has the probability of you
being able to eat and cover the cost of
basic software services but there's no
big 500,000 or $50,000 or $20,000 outlay
for you to come out of the ground being
a consultant yeah that's I think Dave
people think if you build it they'll
come and I think it's the opposite
you've got to go get them and then build
it while like you've got to build it
while they're coming if you build it
they will come in the movie world is
called the Field of Dreams the business
world is called a field of
nightmares so no yeah you don't you
don't want to do that you need to have
you need to have the some you know I
tell our guys all the time hey elephant
hunting is great but they're a lot more
rare than rabbits you eat really good on
rabbits there's lots of rabbits go get
the rabbits and occasionally you stumble
into an elephant then that's extra but
let let's go get the rabbit let's get a
business model that churns cash here
stack some cash you're fine JT do not
borrow into the vagueness that you are
describing us you're really going to
make a mess